[Music]
can you believe
that this man got away like he drove off
with a 140 thousand dollar
porsche 911. oh i like those cars it's a
fake
check he just printed a check out at
home
and he went to this dealership and and
he just drove off do you think nobody's
done it in so long
that they're just like there was a
vulnerability because of that because no
one [ __ ] with checks anymore
yeah because usually they gotta verify
it they do all those things we wait till
the check clears and then they let you
drive off but
but not in this case wait do they
normally like wait for the check to
clear
yeah that's what they were saying that
usually that's what a lot of places do
did he take a picture in front of it so
he was so
like cocky about it that he asked the
employees at the
dealership to take a picture of him
because he's like yeah
cause he paid with the cash right that's
a 911 turbo
for 140k i mean it pulls it off better
you know to ask them to take a picture
of you because you're like you're so
confident it feels real that way but not
like he's like oh [ __ ] i need to get out
of here
i picture this for the police so they
know what i look like
who's keeping that photo i guess if it's
if it's in his phone
did he use all his actual information
though or is it all fake information
this is the thing well i'll get to that
point but after this here you go mr
dumpty
humpty that's an interesting name that's
stupid
no so then after he drove off with this
car
oh well by the way he printed the
checkout for 139
203 dollars and five cents so it was
like exact
and yeah he had just like all this
confidence and that's why they were just
like well i guess it should be okay
so he drove off and then he was so
shocked that it actually worked he went
back home
printed another check for sixty one
thousand five hundred and twenty one
dollars and used it as a jeweler
the next day at a jewelry store but at
that time the owner didn't let him leave
until the check cleared
because he was trying to buy three rolex
rolex watches
and so they they were just like you're
not walking out with these watches until
this check clears so then
at that point when the jeweler found out
and reported that the check was fake
that's when the
porsche dealership ended up figuring out
that it was a fake check too and they
had arrested him and so when he got
arrested
he said that he didn't know what the big
deal was and that since it was his
account number on the check
that he thought it should be fine actual
account number i would please stupidity
too
yeah you have to at that point that is
[ __ ] i don't know how much money he
actually had in his account
so i know right i thought i had 140 000
sitting there
no that's only a dollar and fourteen
cents sir no human
balls
so his name is casey kelly casey kelly
anybody with two first names
yup and no eyebrows it's always in the
eyebrows three first names
casey william kelly oh well then he's
gonna kill president if he's got three
names yeah
he where did his eyebrows go he looks
like a kennedy
maybe he draws it in because he's always
in disguise
each time he draws a different one and
they're like who is this guy
it's only the [ __ ] eyebrow you know
what's funny is that he uses real bank
account
he probably used his real address
everything when he got the car
so he might have legitimately thought
this was a
legal thing or like a loan or something
i don't know like
maybe he just doesn't know how the
banking system works because like
the funny thing is doesn't he know that
if he uses his address and everything
that he's the cops are just gonna find
his ass
but you think he's like he's like well
nobody found out my house isn't mine yet
i gotta cut that with my checkpoints
like i've been here for months
he's just been printing checks all day
yeah he's just been printing checks at
home
at least he has a good printer wow you
guys ever get tempted when you get those
checks like by the banks and loan
companies they they give you a fake
check of like
fifty thousand dollars and you're just
like man i can [ __ ] cash this in
right now
pre-approved for fifty thousand dollars
i love that [ __ ] all you gotta do is put
your name and go to the [ __ ] bank and
then it and then you can cash that
[ __ ]
it always looks like skeptical even with
real checks i'm like wait is this a real
check
i don't know because i'm always so like
it's a scam everything's a scam
especially after buying this house we
got a whole bunch of like homeowner
things being sent to us and i'm like is
this a scam is this a scam i don't know
if you didn't ask for it it's a scam
well there is this one thing that
i kept thinking it was a scam but now
i'm getting scared that maybe it's a
real thing i have to hit up kevin
you asked for it well it's like a
property
ownership transfer thing i don't know
but i was like oh [ __ ] this looks legal
i should probably
you know what's annoying the [ __ ]
senses people like oh can they [ __ ] off
already they
dude they come every day now wait to
your house
they leave the [ __ ] census thing and
tell me to file and [ __ ]
i don't want to why do i have to like
the more they push me the more i don't
want to do it you know when you when you
do it then they don't come anymore
and it only takes like two minutes no no
no it's the principle it's super fast
dude i'm not giving them what they want
yeah i don't know that my question
you do it in person or you do the
ongoing yeah
i like statistics but why i'm not even a
resident there forever
i'm gone that's not my house you're a
resident of the united states of
california oh yeah
the united states united states of
california dude have you been getting
more scam calls lately i'll be getting
scam calls
my phone's always saying like spam risk
dude we'll give him at five in the
morning now sometimes you know silence
unknown numbers
my phone never rings anymore oh buddy oh
hook me up yeah
i need your settings it says silence
unknown numbers so
like your phone will never ring
eventually my phone rings regardless
so does it go to voicemail and then if
it's a voicemail then it just pops up as
a voicemail oh cool that's pretty smart
that's so simple i want every time i see
an unknown number i'm like just leave a
voicemail if
it's wrong but what if it's like your
friend from jail well they will leave a
voicemail well
actually might just say jail it could
say
save the jail number it might that's
pretty good i don't know i don't
i don't like it when people call me you
know it's like if i'm not expecting your
call don't interrupt me
like that's [ __ ] up before i think it
made sense when we had landlines and
[ __ ] like that it made sense
because it's like you that was the only
way that was
normal culture now i think proper
etiquette
is texting wait so you texted me and i'm
like
this is too much [ __ ] to reply and i
call you were you mad at that i'm
expecting your call though
oh so that's different because texting
it's like hey are you free
calling is like i don't give a [ __ ] if
you're free you need to be on my time
[ __ ] i miss phone calls though
man i like to be honest i like talking
on the phone i just don't like that
people
expect that i'm doing nothing so while
i'm picking my lemons right
let me pick my goddamn lemons don't call
me i'm doing something important right
now
i want to be ready for the call i want
them to text me that they're going to
call me
because when they call me out of nowhere
i'm like whoa what's going on i think
that's most people these days
i think people don't call so it's
anxiety
inducing because you're like did
somebody [ __ ] die because you never
called them
exactly what's going on like david
[ __ ] was trying to call me get it get
to me
and then he just wanted to drop off a
bento box and i was panicking like what
the [ __ ] happened
was he in route or was he at home
chilling i don't know
but it was enough for me to ask bart
what's going on because he never called
instead of calling him back
he's like let me call bart yeah well he
wouldn't pick up
oh okay that's funny you're immediately
go to like
is david okay what's going on i don't
know i thought it was an emergency and
he goes
yeah man i'll um i made a bunch of bento
boxes i was wondering if i could drop
one off to your house and i'm like
oh yeah come on but you never call me
why did you call me what makes you more
pissed uh when they call you or they
just show up at your house
when they call me what because if i'm
not home they can show up all day long
i'm giving a [ __ ]
and then if i if they don't if i'm if i
i don't know
uh if they show up because sometimes
people show up because they're just kind
of like chilling in the area
yeah i like that it's a pleasant
surprise except for my parents
oh yeah yeah but everyone else i like
nikki hates it though nikki needs to be
prepped if somebody's coming
well it kind of makes sense because i
don't mind opening the door and i'm like
in my shorts and then my house is a mess
and i'm like i'd rather see you
but most people i think they have
decency so they're like wait you didn't
even prep
and [ __ ] do my [ __ ] you know it's
like catching her out naked or something
if someone's coming over does she like
spend the whole day cleaning and hiding
yeah that means all that [ __ ] it's a
nightmare
but actually we've actually kept our
place pretty [ __ ] clean like she just
redid our kitchen kind of she looks so
good it looks really good
yeah don't worry about some more like
the under cabinet lights that i've been
wanting to get but then i saw it on hers
i was like i'm buying dude you put under
cabinet lights in your kitchen and it
just makes you look like a baller
oh yeah it looks nice it's sick looking
so yeah so since we did that it just
incentivizes you to keep it clean
because it looks nice so so we just been
keeping it more clean
don't you guys get weirded out when
people knock on your door oh yeah
i never opened the door instead of what
like ringing the doorbell it's just
texting you that i'm coming over i'm
outside i had a neighbor recently come
to me because you need to get a
signature
just to smoke on his own porch outside
because like neighbors were bitching or
whatever
so i was like [ __ ] yeah i'll sign for
you i'll sign for you to be able to say
would you do that
okay he just wants to smoke outside
you're gonna smell it it's gonna go in
your house
that's how they're making them sign up
that's not going to my house go in my
neighbor's house okay
nice when the census people come over
they knock on the door yeah
and i stand and i go nope did you know
census people they can go
into places that say no trespassing why
it's
uh it's part of like their thing they're
allowed to government stuff
okay so why is it so important that i
sign up for the census thing
how does it benefit me well it
distributes money correctly to the
states
in the city it benefits you it's
actually pretty vital to the states but
i want to [ __ ] about it anyway
really yeah okay yeah because they need
to know who who's where
why and all that kind of stuff so which
is a single male asian
in a household so yeah that's valuable
that's all they need and then and we're
gonna get a million dollars for
california all right i'll do it only
because of you joe all right let's do it
let me contribute we're still not gonna
see the million but they'll say they
gave us a million
i know but i just don't like how they be
coming over like a bunch of jehovah
witnesses
like knocking on my door and [ __ ] i'm
like man you gotta make me put on
underwear [ __ ]
you know how they feel they're like oh
my god this literally takes like three
minutes to fill out why the [ __ ] do we
have to keep coming to joe's house he
doesn't [ __ ] do it like why is
everyone so cagey about just answering
our stupid questions
hey if it wasn't for me they wouldn't
have had a job
you're that guy it's the best job
security for them
yeah job security i'm leaving all my
trash on the ground for them
i hate those guys oh have you seen this
it's kind of staged but in china there's
this guy that kept throwing trash out of
his
yeah like window and then there's a man
that comes you know sweeping it up and
then some
savior walks up grabs all the [ __ ] and
throws it in the car it's very
satisfying
but it's totally staged there's a
compilation of like motorcyclists who do
that
here yeah that's that's not staged
though yeah yeah they'll go up
they see like someone throw out a cup
they'll pick it up throw it back in the
car and then ride off
i love that it's crazy instant karma i
hate people that
[ __ ] litter you [ __ ] 30 bucks it's
your own city why would you litter you
idiots ugh
yeah because then they live in the
[ __ ] pigsty in their own home so
they're like oh this is just an
extension of my house
i hate it so inconsiderate i like taking
the trash out of my car and bringing her
car
that's not littering because you're
keeping it in the same household yeah my
car stinks
so what do you do you get all your
sandwich wrapping all that and you go
all my empty water bottles put in her
cup holders the pea ones too
don't understand littering it's
disgusting get it either
i don't understand i don't get it only
biodegradable products
like what like banana peel that one
takes a long time banana peels
maybe sunflower seeds have you ever
spilled on yourself accidentally and the
cup was hot so you actually just threw
it out of the window and you're like oh
[ __ ]
nope i did that that was my one lunar
box yeah why would you
put it on yourself you're like oh [ __ ] i
spilled i had the window down already
i i had like a hot coffee i don't really
drink coffee but i had to drink coffee
that day
and i took a sip yeah i [ __ ] spilled
it and i was like oh [ __ ] and i threw it
right out the window
accidentally i mean did you pull over
and go get it
no i was like on the freeway that sounds
funny as [ __ ] i imagine if i was in the
passenger seat that would be funny
i didn't like that i did it i was just
like i [ __ ] [ __ ] and i was like oh
[ __ ] because
like it's just a casual morning you're
like oh [ __ ]
and in the motorcycle this goes you
[ __ ]
it's so hot no then he's like burning
his own hands it's a mistake
[Music]
bye